let's take a closer look at the omicron
outbreak with dr michael osterham
director of the center for infectious
disease research and policy at the
university of minnesota good morning how
are you doing good morning fine thank
you
now the the covet cases the numbers are
rising should we be worried
well of course we should be worried as
we have for the past two years what
we're seeing right now though is a very
different part of the pandemic than
we've seen in those past two years and
that is with omicron we are going to see
a viral blizzard over the next five to
eight weeks in this country we're
already beginning to see these very
large numbers you're talking about
they're going to increase substantially
the true question we have is how many of
those will then actually become severe
illnesses requiring hospitalizations and
even deaths and that's the challenge
we're at right now we don't yet quite un
we don't understand that
now as we heard in nikki batista's piece
uh many people are reconsidering their
new year's celebration so so what advice
do you give to individuals out there
that say you know what i still want to
party and have a good time as i bring in
the new year
well first of all we have to be really
clear and say that if you're already
vaccinated and you have that third dose
some call a booster i like to think it's
part of the whole three dose you really
have a much much higher level of
protection against becoming
infected seriously ill or in fact dying
but you still have a risk of becoming
infected and so to avoid that and
becoming infected and potentially
transmitting that virus into others yes
avoiding these large crowds are really
important if you're someone who has not
been fully vaccinated if you're someone
who has an underlying immune compromised
condition or puts you at risk for
serious illness the last thing you want
to do is expose yourself to this virus
it's so highly infectious
so i think while people are really
frustrated they are tired we all know
the what has happened to us over the
last two years this thrust with omicron
over the next six to eight weeks is so
significant please just let's get us
through this one and then i think we're
going to see a light at the end of the
tunnel through the rest of the year
yeah we hope so um i want to touch on
the cdc guidelines in a second but you
mentioned boosters so you know we're
hearing from johnson and johnson this
morning and they're saying that their
booster
it will protect you
up to 85 percent effective when it comes
to the omicron variant
what do you say about this news that
will be coming out
well i think it's very important news we
all look forward to the release of the
full data later this morning to look at
that but i think the point to make is
that omicron in of itself doesn't
overtake the vaccines
meaning that if you're vaccinated that
you have protection the problem we have
though is this surge is going to occur
in the next three to eight weeks and it
takes at least 14 days just from the
time you've had that third dose or with
the j and j that second dose before you
see increased protection so you can only
count on these vaccines working if you
already are there
you can't suddenly play catch up right
now still get vaccinated we've got a you
know a long year ahead of us but at the
same time know that you have to protect
yourself in the absence of vaccine if
you haven't been vaccinated yet because
it just takes that much time for your
body's immune system to respond
yeah when we protect ourselves we
protect others the cdc they are getting
a lot of pushback for their new
guidelines you know should there be
antigen testing along with this you know
new isolation guideline
well first of all i very much support
the cdc activity i have to say that this
was not something that was
motivated by just an economic issue over
the course of these next uh six to eight
weeks that i've been talking about we're
going to see an unprecedented situation
in this country where many many people
become infected we're already seeing
health care systems that are already
stretched
to deal with cases before omicron came
along now potentially losing 10 or 20
percent of their workers critical
infrastructure losing 20 or more of
their workers
and what these guidelines are really all
about is how can we maximize and in this
very imperfect situation with an
imperfect solution to say you know what
most of the transmission is going to
occur at this time period by the fifth
or sixth day yeah you know we need you
back into that workforce area not for
money for the very sake of trying to
keep life moving forward
and so i think that this is really an
important
activity they're taking on i wish it was
better i wish they had more masking data
et cetera but at this point i support
what they're doing
dr ostom thank you so much helping us
navigate through the new year and of
course covet have a good one thank you